greetings I'm Philip Zimbardo professor
emeritus of psychology at Stanford
University where I taught for more than
40 years and now I am also the president
and founder of the heroic imagination
project we are a San Francisco based
nonprofit whose mission is to inspire
and train people young people as well as
people in corporate America how to stand
up speak out and take action in
challenging situations that you face so
there are two kinds of heroes one is the
impulsive reactive hero somebody who
sees a child drowning and jumps jumps in
and the river to save him we had a great
case in New York a few years ago of
Wesley Autrey 50 year old
african-american man standing on a
subway station at City College 137
Street when a person falls there off the
platform across the tracks being in New
York he knows subway trains come in
every every few minutes there were 75
people on a platform what do they do
it's the bystander effect they all look
away not me he has a reason not to get
involved or as he turns to a stranger
and says please take care of my kids he
jumps down on the tracks puts the guy
from beach across the tracks to between
the tracks puts himself on top and
presses him down just as the train goes
over their head he survived by a half an
inch there was a half an inch between
the top of his skull and the bottom of
the subway train by another half an inch
or if the guy just breathe it would have
decapitated him and would be a sight
that his children would would never get
over but so Wesley Autrey is an impulse
a reactive hero the other kind of hero
is proactive who reflects somebody who
sees some something wrong some
corruption some injustice has to collect
information has to make a case often has
to get other people on her or his side
an example I want to give is someone I
met recently
it's Michael Winstone he was the one who
blew the whistle on countrywide mortgage
countrywide mortgage is a company in
Southern California
that was really at the core of the
economic meltdown of a few years ago why
because they gave a huge number of
mortgages anybody who applied with no
collateral with no jobs low interest you
know but then after two or three years
all these places we get foreclosed but
what they did is they gave everybody
mortgages and then they bundle these
they mix bad mortgages with good ones
and sold it to banks all over and in the
economic meltdown lots of banks failed
so countrywide mortgage at the beginning
hired Michael Winstone he was executive
at Merrill Lynch had been executive
motorola and his whole team 20 of 30
people came with him and he's doing his
business and suddenly he realized
something is wrong that he's looking at
these accounts mortgages are failing
people can't pay the fee they can't pay
the fee cuz they didn't have a job so he
confronts his boss he says what is what
is our rule what is the criteria of
getting a mortgage the answer he got was
if the person breathes we long you know
it couldn't be more so he was horrified
and he said no this is wrong you know
and there were other things that he
noticed that there was asbestos you know
problems many of the employees were
getting sick and so he challenged he
said he said you know I'm gonna quit I'm
gonna expose this and they fired him
then of course and then they tried to
buy him out he went to trial a jury
trial and he won a settlement of
multi-million dollars now the
interesting thing about corruption at
this highest level his Bank of America
bought bought countrywide mortgage when
it failed and has paid millions of
dollars in lawsuits in legal fees and
the settlement that Michael Winstone won
in a jury trial was overturned recently
by a single judge with no new evidence
that's against the law that can't be so
again my coincidences is fighting that
but all of the fighting means you know
again huge huge legal fees
the good news for me is that I've
lectured with Michael Winston he's an
incredibly refined knowledgeable young
man he has a PhD in psychology
organizational psychology he's joined my
heroic imagination project team as
director of corporate initiatives and
together we are designing programs for
corporations to promote cultures of
integrity to indicate that companies
that model best practices companies that
model the most upstanding principles end
up as most profitable it's not a trade
of profits versus you know the versus
principles